the president's national security
adviser John Bolton is with us from the
White House he's a former US ambassador
to the United Nations
good morning mr. ambassador good morning
glad to be with you
so u.s. allies say that the president
withdrew from the Iran deal and has no
plan B what is plan B for achieving u.s.
objectives well I think Plan B is
already being implemented when the
President signed the decision memorandum
yesterday he began the process to put
very strict US sanctions back into
effect that'll have a significant ripple
effect on Iran's economy and I think it
demonstrates that we're determined that
we're not going to rely on paper
promises we're going to rely on real
performance to stop Iran from getting
deliverable nuclear weapons and you know
what Orion threat that you didn't
mention this morning that they've made
is to increase spending on their
ballistic missile program which was
never covered by the Iran nuclear deal
now why do they want more ballistic
missiles I can assure you it's not to
launch weather satellites or
communication satellites this is how
they deliver nuclear weapons I think it
shows where the regime really is so the
idea here is that the sanctions will be
so crippling that Iran will cry uncle
give up their enrichment of uranium give
up their meddling in the Middle East and
give up their missile program is that
how this is supposed to work that that's
a piece of it the the broader piece is
the president laid out in his remarks
yesterday
anas were going to be discussing with
our European allies we've already begun
as soon as I finish here I'm gonna get
on a video conference call and continue
the discussions with the British the
French and the Germans about going after
Iran's other malign behavior it's
continuing support for terrorism its
military activities in the Middle East
you know one of the theories of
President Obama and Secretary of State
Kerry was that the nuclear deal by
satisfying Iran by releasing billions of
dollars of economic resources would
change Iran's overall behavior across
the region it's had exactly the opposite
effect right now the u.s. does not have
the support of the European allies on
this does that concern you and if not if
not why doesn't it concern you well
we're going to try and work with the
Europeans we have
absolutely shared common objective which
is to prevent Iran from getting
deliverable nuclear weapons we have a
disagreement over the efficacy of the
Iran deal and that's the reason that
President Trump exited from it just to
give you an example in in short order
the president will be meeting with the
leader of North Korea to discuss
denuclearizing the Korean Peninsula as
North Korea committed to in 1992 which
included not simply giving up nuclear
weapons but giving up uranium enrichment
and plutonium reprocessing this by the
way was the European position when
negotiations with Iran started and it
should have stayed that way are you
concerned ambassador that this could
bring us closer to war with Iran
they're already chanting death to
America over there yeah I don't think it
will bring us closer I think Iran is
bringing us closer to war with its
belligerent activity in Iraq and Syria
you know they've been moving missiles
the Revolutionary Guards Goods force has
been moving missiles into Syria that can
hit any target inside Israel that's why
we've seen recent Israeli strikes it's
that aggressive militaristic behavior by
Iran on the ground in the region that's
the real threat ambassador let me ask
you about North Korea the Secretary of
State there now will he be returning
with those three American prisoners well
I don't want to discuss the specifics I
think secretary Pompeo is on a very
difficult mission we expect he'll be
returning leaving the peninsula in short
order and since he's the negotiator on
the ground out there I think we're going
to wait and leave the initial comment to
him all right ambassador thank you very
much for joining us this morning we
appreciate your time glad to be with you
Thanks